for those of you who don't know
there's a 3D vehicle challenge going on
right now there's three weeks left to
create your art it isn't too late
because you know what if your render
looks like this right now that's okay
because that's literally my render I'm
putting all the renders together into a
super sweet montage and would love to
see your render in that Montage if you
want to get started there's a download
link to the files in the description
below but I also want to talk about the
submission link and more specifically
how to submit a proper render that makes
it into the montages no matter what all
right but before we dive in I want to
shout out Rococo who's not only
sponsoring this video but the endless
engines 3D challenge with smart gloves
for third place a smartsuit Pro 2 for a
second and a full performance capture
for first since the beginning they've
been huge fans of these 3D challenges by
giving away suits and gloves but today I
want to tell you about their no suit
needed absolutely free motion capture
solution called Rococo video which is
probably the fastest way to get custom
mocap data into your 3D scene it's as
simple as you dropping a clip of you
doing your thing onto their site and
hitting process and from there it pops
into Rococo Studio their free software
where you can clean things up if need be
and Export and a lot of you guys
actually use rhetorical video in a cool
way for their latest character-based
dating app 3d challenge alright so
Rococo is raffling off a free pair of
smart gloves this month only to anyone
who processes a clip using Rococo video
the tool is absolutely free super easy
to use and super useful when it comes to
adding characters to say your endless
engines 3D scene so click that link in
the description to get up in that raffle
and test out Rococo video for yourself
alright so the submission link is live
as of today the link is in the
description just because there's a
submission link does not mean you need
to submit right now take your time
finish your art but for the artists who
submit and for all the artists who
eventually submit there's always a
handful of artists that end up in the of
the spare I regret that we have to
dispose of you
where am I
don't make it in the montages why
because their frame rate is off because
their frame count was off because their
resolution is off so I'm gonna show you
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you
let's take a look I got a bunch of
renders here all right there's like 400
vendors in here this is the first thing
I do all right I filter by frame count
now this is for the past challenge so
the correct frame count was 144. so
here's what I'm gonna do
all these ones that aren't 144 frames
I'm gonna put them in the pit of despair
I'm gonna scroll down
look at all these ones that oh 145 one
frame off but Clint that's so intense
it's just one frame can't you trim it
you know what if I trimmed all of these
frames and I conformed all these renders
to fit this thing no that's your job
that's your job all right I'm being
harsh on this okay that's your job FPS
pair of dessert despair believe it or
not in jail right away but dude can't
you just come for isn't it the same no
no what is this what is this what is
this 25 FPS the rules were 24. pay the
despair gone oh but what about
resolution
oh okay so 38 40 by 16 20.
that's passable these ones are not
unfortunately
1920 by 1080. unfortunately it was 1920
by 810 also jail now all the renders
left over with the proper frame count
the proper resolution the proper frame
rate I got all the tech specs listed
down here for the endless engines
challenge that's it those artists they
stay in here I drag out their art I drop
it in the timeline and I go through and
judge the render challenge now the pit
of despair artists those renders that
are one frame off maybe that are
0.036 off on the frame rate I'll see
what I can do all right but no promises
you do not want to be in the pit of
despair a few artists make it out
most of them they're in the pit to this
day download DaVinci if you have to like
do what I'm doing I'm on the edit tab
right down here okay look at your frame
count look at your resolution look at
your frames per second make sure it's
good then submit all right I want to get
as many of you guys in this Montage as
possible you can only submit one time so
do it right don't waste your own time
you spent five weeks on this thing
you guys put a lot of effort into this
now if you guys are like me and your
render still looks like a bunch of Cubes
slapped together then welcome to the
club it is not too late to start this
challenge you got a few weeks left to
create something awesome so dive in have
fun with us download the project files
Linked In the description and be sure to
hop into the Discord server as well it's
a great place to get advice from the
community also working on this challenge
as well as get updates on the project
files and whatnot we're also doing
virtual meetups every single Monday
instead of live streams here on the
channel so it's a great word for you
guys to come up for five minutes talk
with me in the moderators show your art
off show it to the community talk about
pitfalls talk about different problems
you might be having and we'll have a
little back and forth and help you guys
out on your renders this time it's
actually Tuesday because of a U.S
holiday so I'll see you guys Tuesday at
noon on the Discord server also we got
challenge merch for the first time ever
we put together these incredible endless
engines collectible stickers there's
only a thousand for sale once they sell
out no more restocks so these turned out
really nice it's a whole sticker sheet
you even see the little details little
cars little motorcycles in the
background it's quite nice these turned
out really cool it's a great way for you
guys to collect a little bit of
challenge swag as you go throughout
these competitions got you guys with a
link down below of course so hop on in
and challenge yourself this month and
create a sweet vehicle render with us
it's not too late I'll see you guys on
the Discord this Tuesday at noon and
I'll be back to stream on this channel
on March 4th to help you guys through
the finish line for that March 12th
deadline good luck with your renders and
I'll catch y'all soon peace
[Music]
peace